Joe asks says that he's been looking at
standing waves in physics and he's
noticed Einstein's equations equals MC
squared and he asks whether a standing
wave could store enough energy to
spontaneously produce mass and Joe
you're right
Einstein's equation e equals MC squared
tells us that what that in principle
with enough energy one can produce mass
you need a little more than Einstein's
equations you need a bit of quantum
mechanics but as far the way we
understand things nowadays you can
produce anything if you have enough
concentrated energy you can produce
particles you often need to produce them
together with their anti particles so as
to conserve certain kind of conservation
of charge so you can produce electrons
and positrons you can produce quarks and
antiquarks you can produce just about
anything what you need is a lot of
energy to convert to mass and you need
that energy to be concentrated it's not
enough to have energy spread out over a
large region because the object you're
trying to produce typically are very
very small if you can concentrate enough
energy in a very small region of space
you can produce very heavy particles and
that's what happens at particle
colliders we in fact look for new forms
of matter never seen before trying to
produce them out of the energy present
in these collisions of protons and
proton accelerator x' they have lots of
energy and that energy is concentrated
in a very small very small region then
we can produce the new particles with
respect to standing waves if you again
were to pack enough energy into
a very small region you could produce
particles spontaneously from the energy
of that way for example you could trap
electromagnetic waves light for example
between mirrors and a cavity much as you
do in a laser and if you put enough
radiation into a standing wave in a very
small region you could create a strong
enough wave with enough energy to
produce for example electron positron
pairs out of the vacuum and in fact
people are trying to do that
not necessarily with standing waves but
by focusing lasers on a small region of
space in which the intensity is so high
that it is possible to spontaneously
produce electron positron pairs